Today we're going to look into how to\h
kneel and how to bow formally in aikido.\h
You have to know that there are many ways\h
to do things in traditional martial arts.\h
What I'm going to show you is one way to\h
do, but by now means is it THE way to do.\h
The more you know about different martial arts\h
and different schools, the more you realize\h\h
that there are different way to do.
This is one of those, and I'm going\h\h
to explain to you why I do those things.
We're going to start by just standing like this.
The way you stand is heels together,
and the feet a little bit less than 90 degrees apart from each other.
The hands have to be along the body like this.
The back's straight and your buttocks should be closed.
The feeling is as if your head is being pulled in the sky.
So you're nice and straight.
The hands are along the body.
What you may see in some pictures of the old masters,
they may show their hands like this,
which for people who do striking arts, can look a little strange
because this is the way you're taught not to punch, but this is not for punching.
I've been told that this is a way to protect your thumbs.
If somebody was to grab your thumb, they would have control over your entire body.
So you can see some old masters standing like this,
with the thimbs inside the fists.
It could also potentially be a protection against cutting the thumb if somebody was to come and attack you.
But we're not going to do this, we're going to stand like that,
because in aikido, we are in a gendai budo, so we don7t need that safety procedure.
How do you get on your knees from that position?
It's quite easy.
You're going to take your left leg back,
like this, not too far back,
and you're going to go down on your left knee.
Left,
right, and then, on your knees.
OK, I'll start again.
Imagine that you've got something on top of your head and you don't want it to fall, so you have to go down straight.
Left knee,
straight down and then,
on the knees like this.
OK, that's for kneeling down.
The reason why you bend your left leg first,
is that when you're in that position and you have a sword,
with that leg down, you still have access to your sword and you can draw.
If it was the other way around, it would be a little less practical to disengage you hip and to draw.
One detail I want to add in terms of kneeling down and going back up,
when you bring that leg back, you have to remain with your toes in kiza.
Kiza means that the toes are flexed on the ground like this.
So knee down,
second knee like this, and only then, do you flatten your feet.
When you go back up,
same thing but opposite,
kiza,
right knee,
left knee,
and back in that stand up position.
So once again,
left knee down, right knee down, and sit.
When you get back up, it's the same, opposite.
You will raise this knee first for the same reason that you want to retain access to your sword.
Then you are going to raise your second knee up and bring your heels back together, and stand straight.
That's it for going up and down.
Once you're sitting, you have to keep your back straight like this,
and your shoulders relaxed down,
with the idea that something is pulling the top of your head upwards.
You're nice and comfortable sitting on your buttocks, straight.
The hands shouldn't be hanging like this at the sides.
They should be on your thighs, and the thumbs should be connecting with your belt.
As a result, your elbows may tend to stick out a bit.
You don't want that to happen because the danger is that somebody could cut your arm.
It's also quite rude, when you're sitting in a line, to have your elbows poking into people's sides.
So you're going to put your hands like so,
and avoid having your elbows sticking out,
elbows, like this, with the back straight.
That's the default position.
Of course, sitting on the knees like this can be a little uncomfortable at the beginning,
but with practice, you should grow quite comfortable doing so,
save some pins and needles after a while,
but for the back, it's actually quite good because it's really straight.
One more detail.
In some schools,
the position of the knees will be different.
Generally, you leave two fists between your knees.
Or one fist for women.
It's both a cultural thing and the fact that women tend to wear kimono,
which of course limits the spread of the knees,
whereas males wear the horse-riding hakama, which has two leg separated,
and thus allows to have a bit more spread.
Some schools actually let you sit like this, much more wide,
for technical reasons, which I'm not going to get into.
In terms of the position of the feet,
you can site like this with both feet side by side.
Some people argue that this allows you to move even if someone crushed one of your feet,
you can actually get up more easily.
Others will advise you to sit with the big toe on top of the other one.
Other people will sit like this with one feet completely on top of the other.
What you do is up to your personal preferences, whichever is the most comfortable.
Personally, depending how I feel on that day, I might sit like this,
or like this, depending how I feel in terms of comfort.
Now how do we bow?
There are different ways to bow and I'm going to show you two ways.
One is more formal, and the other is a little bit more casual,
but it's actually the one I use and I'm going to explain to you why.
So the formal way will be...
You're going to bring your hands in a triangle like this,
in front of you, and bow like this.
Now for the formal way,
you're going to bring the left hand first,
followed by the right hand,
and then you're going to bow with your nose going in that triangle.
The reason why you bring the left hand first is a safety check.
As you bow and you're facing people that you don't necessarily trust a 100%,
you're going to bring that hand down, and check what's happening around you using your peripheral vision
and is it safe to bring the second arm and go down.
Why the left arm?
Because the left arm is less important than the right arms, which is the one going to draw your sword.
By sticking it out like this, it could potentially be cut,
so you prefer to offer you left arm than the more important right arm.
So left arm first,
look, peripheral vision,
safety check,
second hand like this, triangle,
and then down, like this.
When you go back up, right hand, left hand and straight.
Once again,
left, right, down,
1, 2,
right, left.
I've said that it's the traditional... not the traditional way, excuse me, the formal way.
Because we're doing aikido, which is a gendai budo,
which is by nature more peaceful than the arts of war of the old times,
we tend to bow like this,
both hands at same time,
1, 2,
back up, both hands at same time.
What it means is that I'm no longer doing a safety check in front of you.
There is a sense of implicit trust
in the person's who are facing me.
That's what I tend to do when I'm in seminars, when I'm teaching,
because I like to manifest that trust in the people who come to see me
because we're in aikido, again, a gendai budo,
a "ningen keisei no mich", a way to become better human beings.
So I express that to you through my motions, by not doing the safety check.
Now formally speaking, what usually happens,
is that the teacher will do that safety check in front of his students,
because there is so much that he can trust his students,
however, the students, in return, will not, they will bow like this,
to show their full commitment to their teacher.
Another time is when you bow to the shomen or the kamiza,
because when you bow to those, you're showing your respect to the dojo, to the founder of the art,
potentially to the kami, the spirits,
so you do not perform that safety check when you bow to the wall of honor of your dojo.
Now you know how to do both so you can pick which one you decide to do according to the circumstances.
Ideally when you bow, you don't want to round your back like this,
and the nose has to go straight down,
you neither look ahead of you, nor do you put your head in,
and you try not to lift your buttocks too much.
Some schools will show you that instead of putting your hand flat like this in a triangle,
they will do that sort of shape here,
they argue that having that shape like this
will prevent somebody who might push on your head like this from breaking your nose,
or prevent them from asphyxiating you.
Again, when I bow, I keep my hands flat in the sense that I'm not doing that safety measure.
Same reason, because we're doing a gendai budo.
Another thing that teachers have to consider,
is that they have to bow to both the shomen and their students.
They're going to have to rotate their hips.
To avoid having too much of a sloppy motion,
you may have to consider how to move your knees, and I'm going to show you how.
If you're going to turn towards the shomen, one thing you can do is raise the right knee like so,
and you'll use that knee to chase the left knee.
Like this.
You raise the left knee,
and then you bring it down and you can site in front of the shomen and do your bow.
When you're done, you raise the right knee again,
chase the left knee, like so,
bring the left knee down,
and back towards your students, and you bow.
So this covers the basics of standing, kneeling, and bowing.
I hope it helps you when you practice in your dojo.